and if you live in the northwest part of
the valley you're going to want to
listen to this police say they are
seeing a big spike in carjackings and
car thefts
in that particular part of the valley
erko mana shares the story of one family
who faced a truly terrifying situation
but he also breaks down how you can
protect your car and yourself
police say one thing you can do to
prevent carjackings and car thefts
is when you get home at night be sure to
back your car into your garage while
looking at your surroundings
and when you get inside and close the
garage door make sure you stay with your
car
until the door is completely shut
shocked i was just shocked
brian enige says he was taking out the
trash sunday morning when he heard a
noise at the gate of his northwest
valley neighborhood
he had turned his car on to get the ac
going but when he came back
somebody was coming behind my car
already into my garage
iniguez says a man stole his car at
gunpoint
once he was reaching for my door my
thing and then i saw his right hand come
up i was like okay that's it
the gun just came pointed to my face the
man then drove away
all of this unfolding while enig's wife
nicole and their children were sleeping
inside
you see these things happen around you
know las vegas
and you never expect it to happen to you
in the comfort of your own home in broad
daylight
and it's part of a growing trend
according to metro police statistics car
thefts in 2021 are up nearly 32 percent
in the northwest area
compared to the same time last year
retired henderson police captain michael
johnston says you should never leave
your car running unattended
and there are steps you should take
after you park rolling up your windows
locking the door taking the keys with
you that is
critical to keeping your vehicle safe to
be extra secure you can also buy tools
like a club or brake lock which will
prevent the car from moving
some of those products work extremely
well as a deterrent
the iniges family tells me police found
their car hours away but it's not
drivable anymore
while they drive their rental for the
time being they're already taking more
safety measures such as buying a
surveillance camera
and they want everyone to learn from
their story it's a serious matter
so i think it's important for everybody
just to be very diligent no matter where
you are orkomana
8 news now